uh i thought i'd start by
asking and attempting to quickly answer
a question which is
what just happened um what just happened
over the past
six nine it's nine months by now and
i i came i've been thinking i was
thinking about it for a while this
afternoon and i came up
with a well two sentence answer
and it's first financial markets around
the world stopped working
last fall and this had a dramatic effect
on the real economy a bad effect
i'm not saying there weren't tons of
other factors at work
there was a very strange mortgage market
that we developed in the us
with so much support for the concept of
home
ownership that sometime over the past
decade or so evolved into basically
government support for really lacks
lending standards
i'm not going to argue that the
government responds to the initial
problems with financial markets that
began
almost exactly two years ago this
week weren't disjointed and
inconsistent and in some cases probably
made things worse
but you still can't deny even if you
think it's all the government's fault
that financial markets
stopped working last fall and i'm of the
camp and there's no way to prove this
but it seems like the more reasonable
explanation
that without the government intervention
we had last fall however
uh clunky and unfair and
um well goldman sachs friendly
it was has left us substantially better
off
than we would have been if government
hadn't stepped in last fall
so that's the basic starting point here
financial markets failed they seized up
they stopped working they went to put
whatever
verb you want to use and here's the
interesting thing
the dominant academic theories for the
past 50 years of
how markets work and how economies work
don't
really leave any room for that
possibility
there's really no theory in the
textbooks that you get in finance
classes in business school
or for the most part in economics
textbooks
that explains why suddenly markets stop
working nobody wants to trade with each
other
everything seems to be on the verge of
breaking down now i will say there there
are lots of
people professors and phd students who
are studying these things and have their
theories of it but in terms of
the dominant paradigm of thinking about
financial markets that's evolved
that just doesn't happen you don't have
bubbles you don't have crashes they're
not part of the discussion nobody has
good explanations for them
so this is what i'm calling
the myth of the rational market this and
and i got a
very long email today from a finance
professor at uc berkeley mark rubinstein
who made the excellent point at one
point in the email that i never actually
define in the book exactly what i mean
by a rational
market so i'm going to make a
kind of an attempt here and it's
basically it's it's not any really
formal definition
in in the end what that term is is it
was a
book title that we picked that seemed to
work it was initially going to be um
i think my agent and i when we first
sold the book had this very
non-committal title arguing the markets
and that wouldn't have gone anywhere and
then my publisher came up with the myth
of the rational investor and then about
two years ago this
project is something i've been working
on for a while i thought no it's the
market we're talking about not
individual investors
so at one level it's a marketing device
it's not a
brand new theory of the world but at the
same time
i i'm pretty con i'm very convinced from
the years i
spent studying this and also just
watching the reactions of regulators and
and lots of other people to the events
of the past couple years
that there was this widespread belief
that financial markets
basically got things right they didn't
need to be exactly right all the time
but they were right
they could be relied on and they could
behave in this
calmly reasonable matter manner most of
the time
and so the question is where did that
idea come from because there have been
awful lot of episodes over history of
markets not doing that of breaking down
i mean going back to the
the dutch and their tulips many many
years ago and and
and it went on through the english and
their south sea financial bubble
the french and their mississippi bubble
and then by the 1800s these
bubbles and crashes were happening
almost every 10 years or so
one famous economist william stanley
evans even
came up with this whole theory about how
it had something to do with sun spots
that that's what was causing financial
crises and then right around
when he he died in the 1870s it suddenly
it was on this 11-year cycle with the
sunspots and then after that it went off
the cycle and never quite
came back um
so we've had these bubbles and crashes
all this time so why did we come up
with this theory of how markets work
that
didn't have any room for them and
that's what a lot of my book is about
and
what i was trying what it is i i think
in a lot of ways is
that people people's ideas are products
of their times
and in the 1950s and 1960s
uh memories of the 1929 crash and the
subsequent well and it just the market
kept crashing for several years after
that and the depression
were starting to fade and markets
actually did behave pretty calmly in
those days
and it just seemed for certain purposes
and it is for certain purposes perfectly
valid to just assume
that okay markets markets can be thought
of
as these rationally functioning
functioning entities
another really big reason why this came
along and the the idea that
markets work pretty well not just
financial markets but all markets for
products and services everything else i
mean that's been part of economics
since the beginning and it's a valid
idea markets are brilliant at
aggregating information
and it making decisions quickly and it
just figuring out what we should make
more of and what we should make less of
but this new at the same time
more careful but also more dogmatic
version of
this theory of markets grew up after
world war
ii and i think a lot of the reason was
that
during world war ii
economics was changed in into a much
more
mathematical and statistically oriented
discipline
partly because economists were involved
in the war effort in these remarkable
ways using statistics to help beat the
bad
guys and one of my favorite stories i
learned in the course of this book is
there was this organization called the
statistical research group at
columbia university and it was this
amazing group of young statisticians and
economists
including the father of one of our
audience members here
um and including paul wolfowitz's dad as
well and including milton friedman
and one of the questions that they were
that they dealt with was
with artillery shells and i'm no gunnery
expert so if they're any here who want
to correct me on the details here but
you score them to determine how many
pieces they break up into
and it's a risk reward thing if you only
score them into a few
pieces whatever if if you hit your
target you hit it with more
and you cause more damage but if you
scored into lots of little pieces
you cause less damage but you're more
likely to hit and so
these calculations of what's the optimal
level of fracturing you want in your
artillery shells were done
up at columbia and then friedman would
go down to washington
and the meet up with generals no not
generals lower officers than that from
the
artillery officers from the army who
were in the midst of fighting the battle
of the bulge they'd come back to
washington to get advice from milton
friedman
on how to manage their ammunition
an experience like that can't help but
make you more confident in your
abilities
and and in what statistics and and math
can do for you
and i think there was just this dramatic
development
in the years immediately after the war
where economics in the us
went from this still largely
literary pursuit where people would talk
about what had happened in the past it
was very historical oriented
to something that was very much
dominated by mathematical modeling
and then when you were looking at the
real world by a very statistical mindset
and so it was sort of natural that in
the in the 50s
chart reading in the stock market was
very fashionable
it was sort of seen as the little guy's
way to get in on making money on wall
street that basically if you
knew how to read the charts you could
predict the future and and
and make money without having any inside
sources or
spending lots of money doing research
and
to some of these uh finance professors
and economists
they could immediately see that most of
these
chart patterns could just as easily have
been generated by
totally random processes and so
they there became this whole little mini
academic movement centered around
mit and the university of chicago in the
early 60s
to sort of prove the random you can't
really prove it but to explore the
randomness of markets
and people would talk then about the
random walk hypothesis and the idea that
basically the future the best possible
prediction of what the market's going to
do in the future is just
a totally random process there is no
secret to what it's going to do and
this is pretty sensible it's not
absolutely true it turns out but
it's it's pretty sensible idea and at
mit
where it really first took hold it was
sort of all the mit professors
thought that yeah markets were really
hard to predict but they were mit
professors and they were really smart
and so they would find little tiny ways
to beat the market by a little bit
using their their advanced knowledge of
statistics this was paul samuelson the
famous
textbook author and economist was part
of this gang
but then this interesting thing happened
at the university of chicago
um they did the same research but people
weren't really interested in finding
ways to beat the market and make money
because it's sort of this whole
randomness line of research collided
with
this kind of libertarian revival that
was happening in chicago then led by
milton friedman
and it became much more a project to
show
that financial markets worked really
well and didn't need the le
and didn't need regulation to the extent
that it was thought and
basically knew best and so that's
it's out of chicago at in the late 60s
that
sort of the most famous part of this
whole rational market idea
theory called the efficient market
hypothesis came
and a lot of people now will who claim
to believe in the efficient market
hypothesis
say that all all it really means is you
just don't know if the market's too high
or too low and i that's part of it
but it was also very much meant as this
attempt to find a way of showing that
the prices prevailing in the market were
right that markets were right
and if you just look at the way things
developed in
the 1970s this idea that markets were
right combined with some new thoughts
about
well we got to give some advice to the
world these finance professors were
thinking
so they decided that they could they
couldn't predict where prices were going
to go but they could
tell you something about the riskiness
of of any particular investment
and and so you got this sort of grand
unified theory of the world in which
there was no point trying to beat the
market
but you could by properly balancing the
risks
come up with kind of the right portfolio
and the right approach to things
and this so
so basically this was the rational
market this is this
market where there is
where prices are basically right and
there is a simple
straightforward way to dealing with the
market which is the name
that it that it got was modern portfolio
theory but it
it's this mix of we can quantify risk
prices are right
now lots of practical ideas came out of
this the first ones were
different new ways of measuring whether
say a mutual fund manager was actually
beating the market
or just taking excessive risks these
things have names like sharp ratios and
alpha and they're still
a big deal especially in institutional
investing
index funds came out of this whole
movement
and there are a lot of good reasons i
can talk about this in the q a why
index funds are a good idea but the
particular
i the they wouldn't have happened in the
1970s if it hadn't been for this belief
in the rational market
and the whole option pricing theory and
world of derivatives again it there are
other ways you can get to it besides
believing that markets are rational but
that's it came from this whole idea that
the prices prevailing in the market are
right
therefore we can build cool theories
based upon these prices
some of the more you know less wonky and
more philosophical ideas that came out
of this where first of all
running a corporation should be about um
increasing shareholder value which you
could measure pretty easily by looking
if your stock price was going up or not
financial deregulation came about for
other reasons than just this idea of the
rational market but clearly
if markets are right and rational and it
made sense to let them free to a certain
extent
and most of all there was this
financialization of american life that
began in the 70s
and again it began in many cases for
reasons just because the old
ways weren't working very well but we
went from having a savings account and
an snl
to having a money market account run by
a mutual fund company or by merrill
lynch we went from
having pensions to in many cases having
401ks where you were completely exposed
to market risk
and these ideas really started
permeating american life
what's interesting is starting in the
1980s when really
in terms of politics and and general
popular beliefs
this idea that the market could be
trusted was
really starting to reach its peak
back on campus some young professors
trying to make a name for themselves
started pointing out all these problems
with this whole elegant view of the
perfectly rational
market world and some of these people
are pretty famous now robert schiller
who you see a lot on tv is a professor
at yale and he's got a
excellent new book out called animal
spirits he
sort of made the point that wow prices
in the stock market sure seem to jump
around a lot more
than any of the fundamental data about
corporations so markets are more
volatile
than seems to make sense larry summers
who's now
running our economy in the white house
he
basically made the point that okay it's
impossible to tell
and irratio a rationally random market
which is what all the
chicagoans and some of the mit people
believed in from an irrational one there
was just no way using the data to tell
if markets were rational or irrational
later on camera search some of it by
some of the same people who came up with
these rational market ideas in the first
place
showing that over time value stocks
cheap stocks do better than others
other research showed that there was
momentum in stock prices that
basically what the market did yesterday
it's relatively likely to do the next
day as well
until it stops that's the problem with
trying to make money off momentum
and then the 87 crash happened and that
was an interesting event in that
it just absolutely didn't fit any of the
risk models that any of these finance
professors had come up with and even
more interestingly
you could argue that it was at least
partly caused by a risk management
technique dreamed up by a couple of
finance professors at uc berkeley
including one of the ones who sent me an
email today and it was called portfolio
insurance and it was this idea to
reduce the risk of investing that
basically involved
them making deals with pension funds and
other money managers to
sell off their stocks really quickly
once prices stopped started dropping
and that can work for one individual
investor or a small part of the market
but what happened is this became so
popular and so fashionable
that prices started dropping in um
october 87 and suddenly all of these
people
were out getting their uh portfolio
insurance programs onto the market
selling stocks to avoid losses which
then caused more selling and more
selling and
and was probably no one can prove this
but it was probably the main
factor why a sort of downward tick in
the market turned into this
unprecedented one-day crash so
there were obviously a lot of problems
with this whole idea of financial
markets as
the things we should allow to rule our
world
but then the 1990s happened and
everything worked out really well the 87
crash turned out not to cause any big
economic damage
um the berlin wall fell so it was clear
that capitalism seemed to work a lot
better than than communism and
even more than that though
if you look around the world there's
certain countries that allow financial
markets a higher
role among capitalist countries like the
u.s and the other
anglo-saxon countries for the most part
give a really exalted role to financial
markets other countries germany and
japan being the main two
leave put the banks in charge and in the
late 80s
there were lots of people in the u.s who
were thinking wow we need a system like
the germans or the japanese by the early
90s
mid 90s the us was doing vastly better
so it just
it seemed like even though the theories
were taking a beating back on campus
in terms of sort of popular view of the
role of markets
i think it really reached its apex in
the in the late 90s
i know i bought into it pretty much this
idea that
it'll markets will take care of it
financial markets will take care of it
and
and you could see it sort of in the way
discourse change this one really clear
thing is up until about the mid 90s if
you talked about
how big a corporation was how important
a corporation was
you always talked about either its
revenues its overall sales or its
earnings
and those are both clearly incomplete
measures but
and and partly because they're
incomplete but partly because of this
infatuation with financial markets
it just made this switch in the mid 90s
and basically all people talked about
was the market cap
it's how much the stock of the
corporation is worth
and that became the ultimate measure of
how important you were
then 1999 happened and it was
pretty clear to a lot of people that
including a lot of old line finance
professors
that pets.com wasn't really more
important than
i don't know delta airlines or
although considering that delta's gone
bankrupt a couple times since then maybe
maybe it was perfectly valid market cap
but the the tech bubble was something
that just
could not be explained very well by any
theory that market prices were were
based on a
rational assessment of future earnings
power eugene fama professor from chicago
who had authored the original efficient
market hypothesis he made this valiant
attempt
that basically there's lots of
uncertainty with these internet stocks
it's entirely possible that one or two
of them will become the next microsoft
therefore it makes sense to assign
pretty high values to all of them and i
think
that makes sense with the the sort of
startup
level companies and clearly google has
sort of and google wasn't out there um
as a publicly traded company yet during
the bubble so
it wasn't there yet but it that's clear
new companies can come along and grow
big
the problem was even the big companies
were valued at these levels like cisco
was the class example
values at levels that required them to
keep doubling in size
every year for the next 20 years for the
evaluation to make sense
so that that caused a lot of questioning
among finance professors and economists
about this idea that
there they didn't have to think of that
bubbles weren't really an issue
that markets could be relied on to get
prices right
but the aftermath wasn't that bad in
large part because the fed came in
pretty aggressively and
and kept the subsequent downturn from
turning into
a very deep one at all and it was kind
of amazing that as as
housing prices rose you had you heard a
lot of the same
arguments made to justify the higher
prices that you heard for tech stocks in
the late 90s
um and it also interestingly the
the loudest voice saying they were all
crazy was robert schiller who
had published a book in march 2000 the
moment the stock market started to
decline
called irrational exuberance making the
point that yes stock markets have a
habit of going these waves of optimism
and pessimism
he put out a second edition with a whole
new chapter on real estate in 2005
making the same point
but the response from most of the
economics professor profession and
um finance academics and alan greenspan
was that you know markets know what
they're doing they
yes there's some new stuff in the
happening in the housing market but we
have all of these great new instruments
derivative instruments they're going to
spread the risk
and take care of everything and then it
all fell apart and
greenspan made his famous uh admission
last fall
he i think he's backtracked a little bit
since then now that the world is less
scary than it was last november
but where he said you know my worldview
didn't work anymore
the whole intellectual edifice he was
specifically referring to
derivatives pricing but he meant it more
broadly this idea that financial markets
could work everything out
has collapsed he said
so and i'm going to go to questions in a
minute here but
my i wrote this book it's not a polemic
it's not an argument it's the story of
the rise and fall of this idea
uh but obviously i sort of feel
compelled to say well what so what do we
do now and i don't have particularly
good answers but
financial markets are not perfectly
rational
we shouldn't allow them to determine
everything
in that our society does
problem is governments are made up of
people too and
people who don't have some of the same
checks that participants in financial
markets do financial markets are better
at
eventually changing their mind when they
get things wrong than governments are
sometimes
so it's not as simple as just saying oh
we need government to play a bigger role
and and regulate more
but it does seem one really obvious
thing
is that financial market
bubbles that are built on debt are a lot
more dangerous than ones that aren't
the tech stop bubble was mostly people
putting
putting their own money at risk with no
contractual obligation to get it back
the housing market was people lending
money with the expectation that they
would get it back
and when they don't get repaid it's a
much bigger deal than if some tech stock
goes from
200 a share to zero so clearly
there's something about leverage that's
dangerous
and there's got to be some better way to
not get rid of it you know obviously
debt has fueled
fueled our economy for hundreds of years
but realized that when it's growing
really fast that something might be
wrong and i think there are a lot of
people at the fed who agree with that
now
that doesn't mean they'll get it right
in the future or that i mean it may be
50 years before something like this
happens again so all the ones who've
come to this realization now will
be long gone by then the the other issue
is just that
markets are flawed governments are
flawed individuals are flawed
uh religious institutions are flawed
we're all flawed but we all have the
every all these institutions have
strength and i think a society works
better
when you don't put one completely in
charge it's pretty clear that an
entirely government-run economy is a
disaster
it's a little less clear that an
entirely market one run
is although i mean we don't even have
one in the u.s we have a mixed one
already but i think just
acknowledging that there's something
positive about the mix even if
the government policies aren't optimal
even if
people behave irrationally it's nice to
have different forces
and not everything determined by the
prices prevailing on wall street
and with that um not very conclusive
conclusion i'm going to come sit down
and we're going to go to questions
thank you so this is now the part of the
program where it's time for us to take
questions from the audience if you have
a question please
note it on the blue cards that should
have been on your seat or on an adjacent
seat
and you should be able to hand those
cards to a council member
to bring up so let me start with
a clarifying question uh previous market
downturns were called panics
well this one be called the panic of
2008.
i on my blog i had a contest i think
this was it was before
last fall though what what we should
call this crisis
um and the problem was first it's the
two years because it really started
to some level in 2007 although i guess
it went to such a new level
in 2008 that we should call it that but
actually my favorite name for it and
there's no way it's going to catch on
but um
it's this blogger duncan black calls it
jenga which is this game that um
actually i'm looking at my son back
there he was playing it in the green
room at the john
on the daily show a few weeks ago
because he has jenga in his in his green
room but it's this game where you
stack up a bunch of blocks really high
and then you start pulling them out
until you see when it's going to
collapse um that's clearly not going to
catch on so i'm thinking
panic of 08 is okay i don't think it's a
bad name for it
but i it has it's not absolutely clear
what the name is going to be that's
which is kind of interesting about this
crisis maybe because people are afraid
something's still going to happen this
year
um so uh there are a couple questions
that relate to
milton friedman's theories and i think
it summed up best with this question are
milton friedman's theories essentially
dead with john maynard keynes
back in vogue keynes is definitely back
in vogue
um i don't think because friedman
came from a bunch of different places
there's milton friedman the libertarian
and at some level all he was arguing as
a liberty because
friedman and i had this conversation
with him before he died up in his
apartment i can't it was just over that
side of town a little ways
he lived on the 17th floor um had
plastic over all the furniture
and well at least in the living room he
didn't in his study i got to sit on a
real chair but
he he's he never believed markets were
perfectly efficient
he just really distrust government and
he also
believed that one thing that had gotten
kind of short changed in the new deal
years and afterwards was this idea that
economic liberty the lib
the freedom to start a business and to
take risks is a form of liberty an
important part of liberty too and i
i think those ideas survive really
strongly i also think
friedman's monetary economics i mean the
the what what he wanted to do which was
to replace the federal reserve with this
spigot that
basically spewed out money at this fixed
rate
over time that has never really worked
in part because it's really hard to
actually measure
how much money there is out there it's
very unclear what the right measure is
but the basic idea that monetary policy
is very important and preventing both
rampant inflation and rampant deflation
i mean that's what the fed's been trying
on the deflation side for the past two
years
and it seems to have succeeded um
whereas
and keynes didn't disagree with any of
that he thought central banks should be
trying to prevent deflation
he just thought that at least in the
case like you had in the 30s when things
got as bad as they did then
you needed more than just printing more
money you needed
government going out and spending it and
i think that's working too but i guess i
guess my thought is i don't think
there's this huge dichotomy between
keynes and friedman i think there's a
huge dichotomy between
keynes and even friedman and this
sort of super extreme version of
macroeconomics called rational
expectations
that arose at chicago basically around
when milton friedman moved out here to
the bay area
in the 1970s and i think that whole
theory is in big trouble i don't think
all of friedman's monetary theories
necessarily are
terrific there are a couple questions
that look to our ability to learn from
the current environment
and so i think the way to think about
this is
have we learned anything and
10 or 20 years forward from today are we
going to essentially
repeat the same mistakes
uh same lines of thinking and reasoning
that we're in today
i don't think they'll be the same and i
and i think definitely there's been this
short term learning on both
on an individual level that gee debt
debt can be dangerous
and i think that's probably the biggest
learning so far and it would be nice if
that became sort of institutionalized as
well that that it and
my problem is i don't have the
definition of what how you define how
much debt is too much or how
when people are getting over indebted
but i do think
any time over the past 25 years and
we've had this really dramatic increase
in especially consumer indebtedness
since the early 1980s
that any time anybody worried about it
and there were many books and magazine
articles written over the years
worried about this horrible phenomenon
of rising debt there'd always be some
economist
to come out and say well you know it's
what the market has determined it's fine
it's going to be fine and
clearly at some point that stopped being
right
it probably was right up to i don't know
1994 or something and ever since then
it's been exciting
and that's the problem it's really hard
to say what the right level is in terms
of other
learnings it's really hard to tell
because it seemed
like about six months ago
that this was this such a shocking
occurrence and
everything was going to change and
nothing was going to work the same
and it doesn't feel like that anymore i
mean wall street's back to making money
and people are back to screaming at
obama about
health care reform and it's just we've
gone very quickly
back to where we were beforehand and and
and so
i would think that even without any
change in regulation and government
behavior that
just the fact that they'll still be lots
of people around
and and active in financial markets for
the next 10 or 15
years we'll keep it from happening for
10 or 15 years
but after that i i don't know so given
uh and you you just touched on this
given the increasing
number of people who are participating
in the financial markets
and the increasing role it has in their
savings
and such can you speak to the role that
psychology plays
in the markets now and in particular
with the rise of the behavioral
economists points of view
when i first started working on this
book i thought it would be this really
simple story of
kind of the rise and fall of this
rational view of how
markets work and it's replacement by
behavioral finance
behavioral economics these ideas coming
more out of psychology and
as i got into it i realized that that
wasn't what had happened at all that
basically
all of these lessons about human
behavior that have been studied and
learned
since the early 70s the the people who
kind of
are seen as having started this whole
line of thought were danny kahneman
and amos tversky a couple of israeli
psychologists who both ended up
teaching in the bay area and kahneman
won the nobel
a few years ago tversky had died so he
couldn't
these ideas are incredibly useful when
looking at individual behavior and
how you ought to design a 401k program
and they've been really influential
401ks in particular have been changed a
lot over the past five years
to reflect the realization that how you
structure them has this huge impact
on how people behave and that there's a
lot to be said for sort of picking these
defaults
that are more or less okay and steering
people into that the amount of money
they save
how the money is allotted and then give
people the choice to change that if they
want but otherwise not so it's
huge impact on both what individuals can
learn about their own
investing about the flaws that all of us
have in dealing with
money in the future is is really what
the combination is
but in figuring out how markets work
it's interesting
that it's been kind of the impact has
been limited there aren't
any great behavioral theories that
explain what
just happened over the last few years
aren't any super great
non-behavioral theories that explain it
either but it's not like somebody's come
along and said
you know i can using the lessons of
cognitive psychology explain
everything that's happened i think dan
ariely at mit has a chapter in his
the revised second edition of his book
predictably irrational that sort of
claims to do that
but i don't think he really manages it
so on that very point many people may be
wondering at this point in the
conversation do we
actually need a grand unified theory to
explain the markets
and what would be the downside of not
having one now that we've seen the
downside of having some that
may not be perfectly accurate i mean i
think it's healthier not to have a
grand unified theory the problem is it's
really hard to knock
an existing grand unified theory off its
pedestal if you don't have a new one
um but maybe that's okay i mean i would
think a much more
sort of loosely understood and loosely
defined
version of this whole rational market
paradigm is it wouldn't be the worst
thing in the world
um but it it does seem that what makes
markets work actually is diversity of
opinion
and so if you don't have lots of people
with
different models of how they think the
world works
then i i think i mean i think it's
everybody agreeing that oh
we need to buy houses in california that
that causes markets to go crazy it's
disagreement actually makes markets work
better
so i'm fine with there not being a brand
new theory um
but i i do think that's one of the
reasons that
some ideas that don't work very well
have sort of stayed in the textbooks and
elsewhere
because they're a grand theory and
there's nothing to replace them
so on the topic of grand theories can
you give your opinion of
of all the government spending that has
been allocated to help the us
economy and some of the thinking that
may be
uh driving obama's current
uh financial agenda well obviously the
initial big government action was just
to throw a bunch of money at the
financial system
so that money would keep coming out of
the atms and
i you can never tell if we really were
at risk of this complete financial
breakdown where
banks stopped giving people money but
that was the fear and that's why they
acted like that and
it didn't happen so that that was the
first it was probably a hugely
inefficient
use of money but it it did seem to work
um
the second part is stimulus and
the idea behind stimulus is just when
everybody's
feeling blue and not wanting to spend
that
if somebody will do it and that's
somebody the only one left
in a time when everybody's animal
spirits are downtrodden is usually the
government
that that can sort of keep the economy
going in a way and
and that's another thing you know in
terms as far as
sort of rational expectations
macroeconomics goes
stimulus can't work but you sort of
watch what's happened over the past few
months and it seems to be working a
little bit i mean
obviously like with cars for clunkers
all these people are rushing out to buy
the cars now that's going to
result at some point when it expires
there'll be a drop off in car
sales but if in the meantime
you've sort of gotten money flowing
through the economy again you've gotten
car makers starting to tool up for new
models you've gotten people
starting to spend on other things then
maybe it works so
there's not really any deeply
sophisticated economic theory behind all
of this
stimulus stuff it's basically that
world war ii the us government spent
just vastly more money than it took in
it was the most dramatic economic
stimulus
ever as far as i know and it worked and
that's basically all that
economists can say well it seemed to
work in world war ii so let's try it
again at a slightly smaller scale
um looking at your son i i have a
question that relates to him so when
he's in his
college economics classes what do you
think the dominant theories of the day
will be
that will drive those studies
i i mean as it stands now i bet they'll
be
pretty similar to the ones we've got now
um
the one area and there are people who've
been talking this up for
20 years is that their
insights coming mostly out of physics
but also other sciences about
complexity and evolutionary dynamics and
non-linear equations
that somehow could lead to a better
understanding of how
economies work and i'm i'm all for that
it's just it hasn't happened yet as far
as i know
although i got this long comment on my
blog the other day from a
professor in p king who says i was
totally unfair in short changing the
work being done
in evolutionary dynamics so maybe
there'll be more of that but i'm betting
a lot of these really basic economic
theories
i mean they're the stuff that's taught
in econ 101
it just it doesn't date back just to the
50s it dates back
200 years actually the bulk of it
was sort of formulated in the late 1800s
and there are
valuable insights in all of it and
i guess the question is you know how
strictly you apply it and how
and this again is something i've heard
from sam savage which is all
all models are wrong some models are
useful
and it's sort of determining uh what's
useful under what circumstances so i
would love
if it's presented in a in a way that's
more okay here are these theories
we use them we stick with them for these
reasons but they don't describe
everything that happens in the world
just to follow up are there any specific
theories that you feel
have been uh truly
justified being thrown out the door at
this point in time
well i mean the clearest one and i don't
know that anyone ever really stated this
as a theory it just was very convenient
to do
is to assume that risk in financial
markets
um works on a bell curve
that basically you have this sort of
scatter graph of lots of potential
events
and most of them will cluster toward the
mean and then
you sort of goes down you'll have a few
sort of extreme events but you won't
have
super extreme events you won't if if if
on an average day the stock market only
moves one percent
you won't suddenly have a day where it
moves 25 like it did
in october 87. um and
that's wrong i mean it's clearly wrong
it's a wrong way of viewing the world
even people who
use this stuff know that it's wrong but
it still gets used because it's
convenient
when somebody calculates the sharp ratio
of a mutual fund which is this
risk to reward performance measure
they're using
bell curve measures of risk and those
little morning star ratings
are based on i don't know it's the sharp
ratio exactly but
they're very convenient and very useful
and therefore they keep getting used
even though they're just as far as
financial
markets go completely wrong
there's some interest in how to think
about
the derivatives markets can you talk
about
whether you feel derivatives and other
second order financial instruments
generally make the financial markets
more stable
or unstable and is the
recent volatility that we've seen and
you spoke about
in your comments the tech boom bust and
the recent crisis
are these normal if you have a long
enough time horizon with which to view
them
um well that's i mean that's one of the
great things about the whole
efficient or rational market world view
over a long enough time horizon it's
absolutely right
on average markets are correct over
hundreds of years um
or even scores of years
as far as derivatives it's actually it's
i think the
the only answer i can give i don't know
um i don't know if
derivatives make markets more volatile
or less volatile and
their story i tell in my book is about
holbrook working
who was this professor at stanford for
years and years at the
food research institute at stanford and
he did some of the earliest research
into
futures markets and the randomness of
futures markets and how efficient they
were
and he but he was always really
interested in this question
do futures markets make the underlying
markets more or less volatile and so
he got this test case in the early 60s
when
congress banned futures trading in
onions
there had been an onion futures market i
guess what happened was
in the 30s when they started doing the
big futures markets were in
in dairy products and eggs as well as
wheat and in in the 30s with all these
new deal
dairy price support programs suddenly
the chicago exchanges lost a bunch of
their
business so they had to come up with new
agricultural products to trade futures
in so they
onions they thought we'll do onion
futures trading and that started in the
40s and it went along for a while and
then
you know at that point these markets
were this was the chicago mercantile
exchange they were very small dominated
by
small numbers traders and so a couple of
the traders in the early 60s decided to
corner the onion market
and so you had this incredible onion
bubble and then collapse
and all these onion farmers who should
have just taken advantage of the bubble
to like sell
you know say okay i'll deliver my onions
at that insane price in five years
they all started joining in on the
market and buying futures themselves and
so all these
all these onion farmers were wiped out
onion prices collapsed almost nothing
and so
they got congress to ban on onion
futures trading so holbrook working
thought
if you could just look at onion prices
before and after this market then you
could learn something and so
initially when it when the legislation
first came in thought well let's look
back to onion markets
before and after they even had onion
futures trading in the first place and
sort of inconclusive and then the the
first test in the 60s seemed to show
um much less volatility
before the ban than after the ban so it
seemed to give evidence that
that things worked better with futures
trading but then somebody else did a
study in the early 70s with a full
decade of data after the ban and it was
the least volatile
onion price period ever and then that's
basically what other research
into whether derivatives markets cause
more volatility have been like they're
kind of inconclusive
it's they don't seem to ruin the world
but at the same time it's not
clear that they make it all that much
better and so
the theory behind why derivatives
especially the explosion of different
kinds we've had over the past
quarter century would make the world
safer is basically
there's this kind of the perfect
mathematical economic theory of the
perfect market
um which a couple of uh
gerard de bruy who ended up at berkeley
and ken
arrow who ended up at at stanford came
up with this and in the 50s
sort of envisioned that you would have
the invisible hand would work perfectly
even in an uncertain world if you had
securities markets
that basically covered every possible
future outcome
and so that the argument that people
made and it was a student of arrows
um who went on to be a derivatives
theorist at mit steve ross who made this
in the early 70s was well gee
that means that the more new derivatives
we can come up with the better and more
better off and more stable our world
will be
and i just i don't know that it's really
worked that way it seems like
yes in some perfect theoretical world
that's true
but in the real world where any time you
come up with a new financial product
lots of people don't understand it and
misuse it and mess up with it
you may be creating lots of new
volatility at the same time
so yeah i i wish i had an answer on on
derivatives but i
i think sort of the confident
pronouncements that alan greenspan in
particular used to make
um over the past decade about how much
they
allowed us to decrease the riskiness of
the world
those those haven't really panned out
on a on a related note there's been a
lot in the press recently about
the growth in the use of exchange traded
funds
and then things that are called inverse
exchange traded funds that take
positions
uh on those markets you also have
uh so you have a lot of new product
innovation in this space
which you alluded to for example with
the onion market
and then you also have a lot of
technology development you have flash
trading and
very quick trading by large
institutional firms
can you talk about how the role of
product
innovation and technology innovation are
driving the markets
and whether theory can keep pace with
both
first of all i should point out that
futures trading in onions is still
banned so don't
try it anybody um
the thing about all of these innovation
and financial markets is
clearly it's it's a good thing over the
long run
the issue seems to be that
a new financial product needs to be
tested through one
cycle one market cycle before you know
that it's worth anything or not
and so the issue is always that there's
just this
since the early 70s there's been this
just incredible boom in financial
innovation
and a bunch of the innovations have
turned out to be either
just completely useless or maybe just
designed wrong
and so i guess the fear with all these
things i just wrote my column
this week i wrote it next to the pool at
my parents house so if you have problems
with it that's probably why
but i wrote my column about this whole
high frequency trading controversy and
when you start looking at it the reason
it's happening is because
we now have this very competitive
environment where there are lots of
different exchanges
um competing with new york stock
exchange and nasdaq and they and they
all need volume to make money
and so these new traders come along who
make new trades every millisecond that
generates tons of volume
and so all the exchanges are catering to
them and trying to do whatever they can
do to get these people to
trade even more with them and it's some
it's
clearly a much better system than when
there was
one exchange basically the new york
stock exchange up through the
through the early 70s that dominated
everything and charged huge commissions
and the the specialists on the exchange
made tons of money using their own
using their private information that
other people couldn't get at
and now the transaction costs you pay to
buy and sell stocks are dramatically
lower so
from that sense innovation has been
great the question that nobody really
knows the answer to is
is there something about this that's
just going to go off the rails sometime
in the next couple years when you're
starting to make market decisions
more quickly than any human could even
hope to
to keep up with and nobody knows the
answer i mean i talked to this
guy buzzy godold who's one of the
pioneers of electronic trading but
sort of checked out about 10 years ago
and he's totally freaked out by it
and it's kind of funny so maybe it's
just fear of the unknown but i also
think financial innovation and increased
speed in financial transactions it's a
mixed blessing
so let me build on that with with a
pretty clear-cut question
how fearful are you about the survival
of a market capitalist
system especially given what you're now
talking about about the
pace and nature of innovation right
i'm a i mean i i'm not that fearful i
think we'll
puzzle it out one way or the other and
and i gotta say at some level we don't
want to completely we're gonna have
financial bubbles and crashes and that's
okay
it's just i think we should structure
our society and our financial regulation
in a way that
that we can survive them and i think we
have to assert except we're surviving
this crisis but
i mean that's easier for me to say
because i still have my job so
it there's been a lot of collateral
damage that probably wasn't didn't have
to happen
um but i i i guess it's just in the
category of i don't know what the
alternative would be
i mean right now china is very
fashionable um and it probably should be
among other emerging market countries
because
there's something to be said for when
you're playing catch-up
for just sort of identifying what worked
for other people
and and what technologies are in other
countries and just copying them
but it's much harder when you're one of
the world's richest and most developed
economies for
any government official or anybody else
to sort of say
okay this is the path things are going
to take therefore we should allocate
resources this way
so i don't see any i mean clearly right
now
we're doing more of that than we have in
a while especially with alternative
energy
um and there's a lot to be said for that
just because
you look at there seem to be real costs
to our current
um energy system and energy uses usage
that it would be nice
if somebody would step in and assign
them to the right people so they would
behave differently so
i think we can always find smarter ways
to
intervene here and there in in the
market economy but no i don't think
market capitalism is is
is headed for a bust okay
um i'd like to shift course a little bit
and talk about your
your column and i'm curious
if you could share with us when you
think pre and post
all the events that we're talking about
now
how have reactions changed um on the
part of people who are reading your
column
how has the nature of what you cover
change
and how does that play out in the
real-time everyday
interaction that you get from readers
online
i mean the big thing that's changed is
i'd seem to write about financial stuff
90
of the time and despite the fact that i
wrote this book about financial things
i'd never really thought of myself as a
financial writer and when i first
started writing my column it would
i really wanted it to range into very
different areas and
i keep saying oh next you know next
month that's when i'll get back to not
writing about banks anymore
um in terms of the reactions
one of the things that's really
interesting is my column
in the magazine i mostly i see it it's
opinionated but it's mostly an
explanatory column i'm not
trying to to raise hell and
and maybe it's kind of the re one of the
reasons is that's just
the kind of person i am but it's also
that when i got to time my column was
often the only economic coverage in an
issue of the magazine
and it just seemed inappropriate to have
it be a polemic
nowadays there's a lot of other
economics coverages in there too and
sometimes i wonder if i should you know
pick more fights
so i don't get huge amounts of reaction
to my column and i think it's because of
that because i'm i'm just trying to
explain stuff not
telling telling people how to think on
the blog
you just get a lot of rea i get a lot of
reaction but it's really
actually i have this loyal group of
about 10 or 15 people partly because we
make the sign in process absurdly
difficult
and i actually like it that way because
i'll read some story on
yahoo finance and it'll have 500
comments and
497 of them will be totally idiotic
whereas the comments on my blog it's
they're mostly pretty smart i
engage with them we argue back and forth
i mean i guess the interesting thing has
been just a lot of real questioning
since last fall about are we going about
this whole
financial rescue and financial
reregulation the right way and
and i don't know what the answer is i
get a lot of
push i mean i would say most of the
pushback i get on my blog
is from people who think we're being way
too kind to wall street
but i have no idea if that's
representative it might just be the
people who
happen to read my blog or time.com so i
love the feedback because it forces me
to
be clearer in well sometimes it just
corrects mistakes
sometimes it forces me to be clear in my
arguments
but i i have no idea if it represents
anything more than the
10 or 15 regular commenters on my blog
uh on the subject of feedback can you
also talk about
the feedback you're getting from
economists to your book
and the general public to your book um
i've started
just in the last couple weeks the very
long emails from finance professors have
started to arrive
and one of the i mean and i sort of
cringed at this prospect because i
really wanted when i wrote the book to
have a bunch of time between when i
finished the manuscript and when it was
actually moving on into publication to
show it to a bunch of finance scholars
and and i just
it i just it didn't happen that suddenly
i i finally got to the point where i was
happy with the manuscript and the
publisher's like we gotta get going with
this thing
um and i the couple of professors i
actually got it to
never got around to reading it in time
so now i'm getting and and for the most
part you know some
there's some little factual errors here
and there that luckily
nowadays book publishers don't like to
print many copies at once so
they keep coming out with new printings
and each one's a little bit more correct
let me see if this one's got any of the
fixes in it yet
um
no this is the rare original edition
with all the typos
and and so i mean the rea
one reaction is well gee you sure
neglected this
particular line of research and my
response to those is always yeah you're
right sorry
um and i'm sure in many cases i'm sure
my decision to neglect it will look
really stupid 20 years from now but
i in the end i mean i was trying to be
as fair as possible and represent
reality as well as possible when you're
looking at
academic arguments that have been
happening in the last 10 or 15 years
there's really no way to tell what
what's going to last
and what's not and so you sort of pick
the people who seem to be the most
compelling characters or
who fit into the narrative flow the best
um i'm trying to i mean in general
everybody's pretty appreciative that
because i think from the title and most
of the
orthodox finance professors expect it to
be this total broadside against them
because there are people out there
george soros is one of them and
there's a another money manager jeremy
grantham who basically blame everything
that's happened over the past few years
on the efficient market hypothesis they
say and
and i don't i i don't go that far and i
i try to tell this story and there's a
lot of validity to a lot of these ideas
so
in general the emails are sort of you
know nice book but
a you you know you've got the name of my
paper and that's something you you've
got something wrong about the paper i
wrote in
1977 or or you
you know missed this line of reasoning
or
or you failed to ever say what you meant
by irrational market which is what was
in the email today
uh so for last question what i'd like to
do is square both of those audiences
that we just talked about the academic
audience that's responding to your book
and then the
everyday audience that may be responding
to your column
and your in your blog do you feel that
there is
an inequity of understanding of
knowledge
that is out there and how does that play
out where it requires phds
and people who are well-versed in
statistics and analytics
to to make sense of the markets on the
one hand and then you have on the other
hand
the everyday person who barely
understands what's in their mortgage
agreement
and for whom as you said you're making
you're helping them make sense of
economic theory
i mean your article how do those come
together and is that destined to
always lead to some tension well i mean
it seems like um
it's a lot less clear now than it was
two years ago that you need to know all
these
theories to understand how financial
markets and the economy work because
clearly the theories sophisticated math
statistics everything else did not allow
these people to
um predict what happened or really
understand why it happened
so at one level i i feel like i mean my
whole goal in this book and i'm someone
who
who struggles with the math and the
statistics and in some
you know as it has a real habit of
reading act
like it's like people who read playboy
for the articles i read
academic economics articles for the um
pros uh not the equations
so i'm one of those people and in many
of these things i'm sure some of the
concepts i just got wrong and a lot of
others i just
would have to have them explain to me
again and again and again and read
articles again and again and
finally come through but i guess what it
is is a lot of
and and this is both the beauty and the
limitation of of the way academic
research works
a lot of academic theories don't really
say that much
um because they're you know you're
trying to be careful and you're trying
not to represent
something more than you can and and
they're just
restatements of the obvious or less
obvious statements of very minor things
so
i guess i don't i do think there's this
concern that if market jargon
completely gets taken over by the quants
then the rest of us will feel left out
but it seems like in terms of
understanding the economy
we've actually taken several steps back
to
a more a simpler basically keynesian
explanation for how things work at least
in a time like this
and and away from a world where
the people with their really fancy
equations can have all the answers
so i feel like the inequity maybe has
decreased over the last few years
because it's just clear that
the economist didn't have all the
answers